[Musik]
der fall annalena baerbock er hat ihn
ins rollen gebracht der plagiatsjäger
stefan weber
jetzt ist er hier zu gast und trifft auf
zwei grüne wie schmutzig wird dieser
bundestagswahlkampf die richtigen fragen
jetzt bei bild ja es ist vorbei der burg
wenn sie das klima retten will dann
sollte sie zurücktreten das sage nicht
ich sondern das schreibt ausgerechnet
die taz also sowas wie das grüne
zentralorgan wir diskutieren jetzt über
diesen fall von annalena baerbock und
das tun wir mit zwei grünen nämlich mit
sarah wiener der österreichischen
europaabgeordneten und wie sie wissen
spitzenköchen wir tun das mit uwe
schneidewind dem grünen
oberbürgermeister von wuppertal mit
hubert aiwanger dem stellvertretenden
ministerpräsidenten von bayern von den
freien wählern und mit cdu-landeschef
aus hamburg christoph ploß außerdem mit
diesem mann nämlich mit stefan weber dem
jahr muss man sagen gefürchteten
plagiatsjäger dem mann der diesen fall
annalena baerbock ins rollen gebracht
hat ihnen allen schönen guten abend herr
weber was empfinden sie erste frage an
sie wenn sie sehen wie schwer sie
annalena baerbock jetzt geschadet haben
das ist eine suggestivfrage ich habe der
frau auch gar nicht geschadet ich glaube
ich habe geholfen
ich habe die entscheidung erleichtert
möglichst schnell zurück zu treten das
feld zu räumen
es kann ja nicht sein dass in
deutschland allen ernstes jemand für die
kanzlerschaft kandidiert bei dem ich
mich fragen muss hat diese person
überhaupt so etwas wie eigene ideen kann
diese person überhaupt selbst
formulieren wenn sie nicht ein internet
ein internet libretto vor sich liegen
hat von dem sie ab schreibt also ich
glaube wir haben in den vergangenen
tagen sehr viel über die eine verletzung
der werte gesprochen und über eine
verlagerung das sachthemen mir wurde
eine ent sachlichen vorgeworfen dann
muss ich sagen ich möchte jetzt
ernstlich dieses thema in den
mittelpunkt rücken
was hier passiert ist und man kann hier
nicht davon reden dass ein buch
geschrieben wurde
das wurde mittels copy base
zusammengestoppelt so dass man es
eigentlich jedem schüler jedem 16
jährigen zurück schmeißen würde sie
verzeihen
diese klaren worte das sind sehr klare
worte gleich zu beginn dieser sendung
legen sie annalena baerbock den
rücktritt nahe
dh da ist kein mitleid dabei ihnen tut
annalena baerbock nicht leid
naja wie sie ich tue mir selber leid
weil ich im moment sehr viel beschäftigt
bin mit der detektion der plagiate in
diesem buch die vorburg ist auf urlaub
ich nicht also ich spüre ich verspüre
doch bitte kein mitleid mit ertappten
plagiatoren nennen ja also das wäre ja
völlig absurd ich habe mitleid sage ich
ihnen ganz offen mit allen lesern dann
nehme ich mich mit ein die dieses buch
gekauft haben und ich hätte bitte gern
meine 24 euro vom ullstein-verlag zurück
oder wie viel das buch gekostet hat weil
das steht nämlich am cover annalena
baerbock drauf und ich habe mittlerweile
entdeckt dass 18 autoren geplündert
wurden und ich bin mir sicher in ein
zwei wochen werden es nicht 18 sondern
30 oder 40 weil ich mache jetzt diese
plagiats detektion seit zehn jahren und
ich weiß dass diese akkumulieren das
wird immer mehr frau wiener können sie
als grüne europaabgeordnete als mensch
verstehen dass sich jemand wie stefan
weber stundenlang wochenlang gequält um
anderen menschen ja plagiate
nachzuweisen
also wenn wir über werte reden dann muss
ich sagen dass meine werte nicht ein
paar fehlenden post not es zu machen
sind sondern dass meine werte in die
richtung gehen dass gerade jahr
verbrennen in kanada dass das hitze tote
geht dass wir alle micro plastiken und
nun haben dass er alle punkte in jedem
wird finden was sind die themen über die
wir reden sollten und nicht ob ein buch
das nicht einmal eine dissertation ist
oder den anspruch einer
wissenschaftlichen arbeit jetzt ein
sternchen kegel auf drei sätze oder
liegt also wenn wir hier reden wie man
weber beginnt etwas inhaltlich als
gefunden hat als produkten hat wo man
sich wirklich den hören kann und sagen
hey die frau
das ist ja gar nicht grün was die
schreibt beschreibbar irgendwie dinger
drin angesehen und sachlich und
unfallschaden folgt ist
deswegen ist eigentlich alles dazu
gesagt worden und wir sollten jetzt ein
paar kinder reden über wirkliche inhalte
und hieß darüber dass werden sommerloch
haben und deswegen nur saugen brücken
zeit in letzten siebtens wert von links
er war schnell dazu weil die frage von
frau wiener kam also wenn inhaltlich
doch alles stimmt sagt frau wieder dann
mensch lasst uns doch darüber
hinwegsehen dass da etliche passagen
einfach übernommen worden
es ist genau umgekehrt ich kann mich ja
mit den inhalten seines buches erst
auseinandersetzen wenn ich der autorin
vertrauen kann dass sie das buch selbst
geschrieben hat das ist ja genau so auch
in der akademischen welt und jetzt
einmal diese parallele zu ziehen
ich muss das buch ja nicht mit
wissenschaftlichen kriterien bitte ich
muss es aber sehr wohl mit dem
zitiergebot und mit dem plagiat verbot
das ist nämlich ein grundpfeiler unserer
kultur unserer unserer buchkultur seit
300 jahren und erst wenig gecheckt hat
dass dieses buch auch von der autorin
stammt nämlich von eigenen
formulierungen sich aus eigenen
kreativen ideen speist themen kapitel
selber strukturiert ein in die zukunft
gerichtetes manifest ist und nicht ein
sampling von fundstellen aus den letzten
beiden jahren internet liebe frau wiener
erst dann immer unterhalte ich mich mit
ihren über die inhalte ich habe doch von
am inhalt nix wenn eine halbe seite vom
club of rome abgeschrieben wird das kann
er nicht ihr ernst sein dass ich mich
eine inhalt sie eine inhaltliche
diskussion über dieses ding führe wenn
ich jetzt schon weiß dass 30
plagiatsstellen und in den zehn tagen
wären es mehr sein in diesem buch
drinnen sind 20 das war das stichwort
dass ich sie jetzt mal unter presse aber
soll man überhaupt mit ihnen eine
wirklich objektive diskussion führen
wenn es ihnen offensichtlich eine
vorgefasste subjektive schon
segmentierten meinung überein
eigentlich glaubt wissenschaftliche
arbeiten und so als ich auf einen
einzigen kandidaten jetzt best buy ist
das ist wirklich gelassen ob die normen
und damit sie gerne machen aber ich
möchte gern hier mit netz stellen wir
haben wichtiger probleme als in einem
bei handbuch rest des geldes brachte
ich meine es so dass ein paar fußnoten
darum geht's bei mir sie haben das
problem nicht verstanden
da müssen wir den druck bei vorbereiten
alex geht in die schlussphase
das ist die feste nicht so schlecht
lassen sie uns kurz nein
und deswegen jetzt schon wichtig wenn
der mal wirklich inhalten über wichtigen
dinge reden und nicht über 20 lassen sie
uns einmal lassen sie uns einmal herr
weber frau wie nah die runde breiter
machen und sprechen mit herrn
schneidewind dem grüne oberbürgermeister
von wuppertal
sie arbeiten ja auch oder haben ganz
lange wissenschaftlich gearbeitet als
wirtschaftswissenschaftler und jetzt
haben wir es hier mit einem buch keinen
wissenschaftlichen buch zu tun aber eine
buch dass ganz viele textstellen einfach
von woanders übernommen hat jetzt habe
ich gerade nach dieser berufung von
herrn weber gefragt florence gaub also
eine derer die dort kopiert werden in
dem buch von annalena baerbock die
spricht von plagiatsjägern als
kammerjäger dieser beruf sagt sie
der stinkt teilen sie das herr
schneidewind also was die plagiatsjäger
und der kann weber ja im
wissenschaftsbereich leisten das ist ja
durchaus ehrenwert weil das einfach
dafür sorgt dass die standards die wir
an wissenschaftlicher arbeiten anlegen
müssen dass die sozusagen jetzt über
diese praktika ja noch mal eine eigene
externen kontrolle erfahren ich glaube
das tut den gesamten
produktionsprozesses und auch der
sensibilisierung gut wir haben es ja
hier mit einem völlig anderen songs zu
tun ein politisches buch da ist es
völlig üblich dass solche bücher
entstehen mit entsprechenden co-autoren
die sind in dem buch höher angegeben
michael ebmeyer war hier der koautor das
sind autoren die in intensiven
gesprächen mit politik und politikern
versuchen das haus zu arbeiten
was die perspektiven der person ausmacht
was sie inhaltlich ausmacht dh da führen
sie ist dann völlig in ordnung dass
abgeschrieben wird
nein das ist nicht zu haben das ist
handwerklich unschönen also hand hält
und schön würden sie sagen dass ich hier
wieder aussagen
töpel oder wieder klappt auch proben
deutlich gemacht hat also da kann ich im
weber durchaus recht geben
also so etwas auch in seinem buch kann
man das anders
okay das haben wir vor allem auch man
bisher nichts gehört das haben wir von
keinem grünen bisher gehört also
zumindest nicht öffentlich das heißt
handwerklich ist das nicht gut gemacht
sagen sie das hätte man anders lösen
können aber es bleibt dennoch der song
eines politischen buch ist so dass
selbst gibt auch das was dort jetzt am
besten dran ist in einer ganz anderen
ebene zu bewerten ist als das in der
wissenschaftlichen arbeit der fall ist
denn dieses buch soll ein einblick geben
wie annalena baerbock deckend was ihr
als eine person ist und ich glaube das
ist wirklich die ebene auf wir haben
dieses buch rezepte jetzt hat herr weber
gerade reingerufen das ist doch betrug
das hat dann natürlich eine juristische
dimension aber vielleicht noch ein
bisschen anders formuliert man schmückt
sich ja zumindest mit fremden federn
würden sie das teilen also ich glaube es
gibt ja auch jetzt die rückmeldung von
vielen autoren autoren ich hab's
normaler gipfel mitbekommen weil sie
fühlt sich geschmeichelt dass ihre
rahmung da entsprechend vorkommen und
wie gesagt das ist an den stellen das
ist handwerklich nicht sauber das hätte
man auch in dieser co autor schafft
anders lösen müssen
es geht doch es geht doch gar nicht um
frau göbel oder ob die sich
geschmeichelt fühlen sondern um den
leser wenn der die gedanken von frau
berbalk liest und später erfährt hoppala
es sind ja gar nicht die gedachten von
frau werbung sondern sind die gedanken
die klugen von herrn fischer von herrn
trittin von frau göbel von frau von der
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
vom club of rome den sie in dem sie
angehören
aber ich weiß und das ist ja das
entscheiden ich weiß was an der werburg
wichtig ist werden mit welchen rahmung
mit welchen inhalten sie sich
identifiziert und wie gesagt das wären
auch sauber gewesen man hätte das an
einigen stellen auch deutlicher
unkenntlich gemacht das entscheidende
ist doch zu sehen welche werte
karl antreibt annalena baerbock an was
ist sie für eine frau welche dinge
bewegen sie dafür sind solche bücher
geschrieben und das leistet das buch
glaube ich in jedem fall und da kann man
sich auch kritisch oder konstruktiv mit
auseinandersetzen
aber ich finde es schade dass so ein
buch das ja auch ein gewissen mut
erfordert dass ich in so einer form auch
zu exponieren dass man dann sind
reduziert jetzt auf diese dieser
handwerklichen und vereine halten die da
vielleicht auch drinnen sind hier
einfach mehr freuen sie sich über den
schaden denn gerade annalena baerbock
erleidet macht herr betreibt herr weber
ihr politisches geschäft
nein wirklich keines baldwin immer am
boden liegt habe ich auch nicht drauf
aber darum geht es hier gar nicht ich
glaube trotzdem dass es tief blicken
lässt und jemand der kanzler von
deutschland wären wie wenn dir nichts
anderes zu tun hat als kurz vor der wahl
noch zu sagen ich auch ein buch
geschrieben und auch ich habe das gar
nicht geschrieben weil ich nicht auch
ein buch zu schreiben dann brauch ich
kein präsentieren und wenn ich meiner
bevölkerung was mit geben will und
einblicke in meine schlaue gedanken weg
geben will dann muss ich die dinge
selber formulieren und sie überschreiben
es geht um eine lange kette ihrer in
beginnend vom lebenslauf und die neben
einkünften und so weiter und in der
gesamtbewertung kommt für mich einfach
eine persönlichkeitsanalyse heraus dass
hier jemand auf dem weg ins kanzleramt
war geschoben wurde von allen seiten
gepusht wurde jetzt einfach raus kommt
aus viel grüne hochstapelei dabei waren
so ist es gut dass wir als fehler dass
wir als bevölkerung dieses landes
rechtzeitig wissen werden die an die
kanzler klopp hätte und ich hoffe dass
wir damit einfach den überblick bekommen
und sagen die grünen können nicht dieses
land in die nächst nächsten vier jahre
führen
das ist sehr jung die pläne die ihren
lassen
interpretation natürliche aiwanger das
ist ja klar hier geht es um von herbert
die widersprüchlichkeit der grünen
das ist das große problem viel show
wenig doch in gibt das sagte der
wahlkampf von den freien wähler hubert
aiwanger plus cdu-landeschef von hamburg
hat gerade gesagt frau per block liegt
am boden
ja also sie hatte sicherlich schon
deutlich bessere fahren das ist glaube
ich können wir alle über angst und
erstellen was mir aber bei der ganzen
debatte auch auffällt ist dass die grün
unterschiedliche moralische standards
wieder ansetzen an sich selbst legen sie
andere maßstäbe an als an die
politischen wettbewerber und das finde
ich inakzeptabel denn wenn man sich mal
an erinnert an andere ragaz erklären da
waren die grünen die spitze der bewegung
die immer wieder gesagt haben so etwas
darf man nicht akzeptieren da raus ist
politische konsequenzen geben und viel
sagen sie auf einmal das ist alles nicht
so schlimm
im irak hat das übrigens auch wer die
union hat natürlich auch in anderen
fällen die eigenen reihen erstmal
geschlossen im fall guttenberg und dann
irgendwann gemerkt dass es nicht nicht
haltbar
also umgekehrt haben parteien und herren
dann sehr schnell konsequenzen gezogen
worden und bei im plagiatsfällen der
union wurde dann auch parteiintern klar
gemacht dass so etwas nicht akzeptiert
werden kann
aber ich finde das verhalten der grünen
nach dem aufkommen der plagiatsaffäre
noch viel viel schlimmer dass zum
beispiel auf medien darüber darüber
sprechen wir noch mal darüber sprechen
wir gleich los dass das feld machen wir
gleich auf mich bei einem punkt bleiben
den frau wiener angesprochen hat sich
nämlich gesagt hat zu einem weber mensch
sie sind da ja gar nicht objektiv
rangegangen ihre
worte jetzt die zeigen doch dass sie von
vornherein nur eines hat
wollten nämlich frau berbalk so
interpretiere ich das jetzt die worte
von romina frau bärbel kaputt zu machen
wie kamen sie herr weber überhaupt auf
die idee dieses buch auf plagiate auf
kopien zu untersuchen
ja also es gibt nichts subjektives fast
auf dieses planeten als eine text über
einstellung übereinstimmung das ist das
großartige und das ist ja auch ein
bisserl das problem ist ja dass die
sogenannten plagiatsjäger von denen ich
gerade zu erfahren ob sie stinken dass
dieses zitat ist mir neu von der frau
glaubte werde mit einer separat meter
vergab unterhalten müssen ja dass die
etwas finden das jahr 2000 prozent
objektiv ist das macht ja vroniplag wiki
auf die idee kommen überhaupt hier sehen
wir noch mal das zitat von florence gaub
heute aus der welt am sonntag dass eben
von kammerjäger anspricht plagiatsjäger
als kammerjäger bezahlt jetzt schreibe
ich ja irgendwie eine motivation das
heißt sie hätten sie ja auch erstmal
sämtliche schriften von der lasche
vorlegen können ganz ohne hinweis von
von jemandem hat sie jemand angerufen
hat gesagt also passen sie auf herr
weber gucken sich das buch mal gucken
sie das buch von frau bärbel auch mal an
ja das war sozusagen mein innerer
instinkt da oben im kopf ich habe es
beim online riesen bestellt aus eigenem
impetus heraus dass ich natürlich jetzt
schwierig den gegenbeweis anzutreten so
zu sagen wenn man jemand sagt nein das
glaube ich dir nicht ich habe dunkle
mächte verständigt oder gar finanziert
das ist eine lächerliche diskussion
eigentlich traurig ja die ist definitiv
kein geld dafür geboten bekommen und
auch kein geld dafür eingenommen dass
sie dieses buch ja so gern ich habe geld
gezahlt über den online riesen für
dieses buch und ich wiederhole noch
einmal ich möchte mir das geld vom
ullstein-verlag zurückholen
unter grund warum ich dieses buch
bestellt hat er weise danach haben sie
mich gefragt ist ausnahmslos die
diskussion um den lebenslauf vorher dass
hier ganz klar wir hatten im vergangenen
jahr mehr als einen fall in österreich
denn die frau wiener auch kennen müsste
eines hochstaplers der in österreich in
einer spitzenposition gehievt wurde auch
mit von einer partei ja nicht der grünen
partei
und da hat mich das natürlich
interessiert dieses thema warum nennt
sich denn jemand doktorandin der sich
schon vor fünf jahren exmatrikuliert hat
mir entschuldigen sie das ist ja mein
metier
so habe ich mir das buch besteht setzt
wer jetzt daraus ein james bond narrativ
machen will der möge doch bitte sehr das
drehbuch für den nächsten james bond
schreiben damit verdiene doch wunderbar
geld aber es hat mit mir nichts zu tun
es ist hintermänner gibt natürlich wenn
es menschen gibt die sie auf diese
fährte gelockt haben sie haben das
gerade dementiert dann ist es natürlich
spannend zu wissen wer war da ist welche
welcher partei gehörte an was hatte der
für die motivation das dem widerspricht
herr weber frau wiener glauben sie ihm
das keiner weise wissen sie ich möchte
noch mal irgendwie wirklich diese diese
bälle diese diese fehlenden fußnoten
richtig einordnen
wie gesagt es ist keine dissertation es
ist eine wissenschaftliche arbeit mit
dem titel holen
die hat man mit mutige und visionäre
sachliche politische visionen und
forderungen gestellt und auf den seiten
wie es ist auf dieser welt und wir
sollten noch lieber darüber reden
in einem kontext ist noch alles gesagt
worden es ist noch mal einen extra extra
wird gedreht
in anbetracht der zahlreichen krisen wie
der hna er hat nur ist doch die frage
kennen und das schon irgendwie in diese
unverschämt zu sagen jetzt im kontext
wie grünen die grünen sind nicht
glaubwürdig die grünanlagen lösungen
die grünen müssen war sozusagen haben
eine gute moral denn ich weiß erst mal
nicht ersten sieg grünen sein sollen und
weiß auch nichts wenn man darüber redet
über eine politische partei sollte man
inhalt nicht darüber reden wer das
vorschlägt werden will oder wer us wie
finanzieren möchte ich trete
jetzt auch nicht darüber und das ist
auch wissen sie das ist eine abschiebung
die lang haben sie über die masken
affäre geredet ja von der kündigung die
lange ist geredet worden
aber irgendwie steuergelder taxi
vielleicht gering mitarbeiter wie von
steuerzahler gezahlt wird eingesetzt um
das buch zu speichern
da wieder es gibt daher wird ich habe
wichtig den preis als da jetzt noch mal
aufgenommen sind ist aber jetzt noch
reuters die müssen jetzt noch gestern
smartes ein antrag nur gesagt na wiener
und doch geht es natürlich hier am ende
um vertrauen um glaubwürdigkeit und wir
haben ein reines gewissen wir haben
natürlich über den im skandal über das
viel zu späte fall impfen in deutschland
ganz massiv berichtet haben ganz hart
kritisiert vor allen dingen den
gesundheitsminister die komplette
bundesregierung aber wir haben über
diese masken affäre innerhalb von cdu
und csu massiv berichtet also ich glaube
da kann uns zumindest niemand vorwerfen
dass wir da mal so nonchalant darüber
hinweggegangen sind wir müssen aber eben
auch über diese textstellen sprechen tor
wieder sie sagen das sind so ein paar
fußnoten noch einmal ganz kurz darauf
geblickt über ja immer wieder neue
textstellen die auftauchen die eben
kopiert sind also beispielsweise hier
von der deutschen umwelthilfe
es wurden runde tisch ins leben gerufen
messehallen stadtteilen und dorfes
angemietet um den austausch zu
ermöglichen die diskussionen der
fachleute planenden und der bürgerinnen
das wurde noch eingefügt von frau
berbalk das gender sternchen waren
lebhaft und impulsiv und so weiter exakt
von der deutschen umwelthilfe
übernommene weitere textstelle exakt von
joschka fischer übernommen da geht es
vor allen dingen auch um einen
bestimmten gedankengang ebenfalls
übernommen eine textstelle im bordbuch
auf seite 2 114 von ihm hier über norm
einem der wichtigsten berater politisch
von annalena baerbock in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf von jürgen trittin
im artikel aus der frankfurter rundschau
und dann geht es direkt weiter eine
weitere
passagen übernommen auch hier geht es um
den gedankengang tatsächlich von
florence gaub aus der internationalen
politik dieser artikel einfach
übernommen und so weiter und so weiter
wir können mit weiteren textstellen
fortsetzen hier vom club of rome
also das ist schon massiv frau wiener
das ist tatsächlich nicht so dass wir da
mal eben darüber hinweg gehen können und
sagen das sind hier so ein paar fußnoten
naja ich weiß nicht ich sehe das ein
bisschen anders ich sehe dass ich sehe
den punkt was sie sagen da ist
vielleicht schlagen
das kann man tieren
man kann aber auch sagen sie jetzt
jederzeit oder jeden fragt man auch noch
sagen wo jemand den arzt vielleicht war
es ein bisschen an ist nichts sagen ein
bisschen cvp selber fragen was die
kinder nach aussagen kann ist was denn
ich schreibe ist was einige rezepte zur
eli hinaus in anderen brauchen sind
hinten werden wenn es um einen
bestimmten ja aber denke ich gerade bei
ihnen aber das ist ein super beispiel
gerade bei ihnen haben die ja ihre ganz
eigene handschrift das wird man wirklich
frau wiener also das schmeckt halt dann
wie sarah wiener und nicht wir haben das
ist ja eigentlich ein schönes buntes
beispielsweise in dem kochbuch
verwendest du ganz viele zutaten die an
anderen orten beschrieben sind
aber das was dann das gericht ausmacht
ist die kombination und hier haben wir
jetzt vielleicht einzelne stellen wo man
vielleicht hätte kennzeichnen können
aber das was hier entsteht ist ja ein
ganz eigenes bild der des blicks von
annalena baerbock auf die welt und ich
glaube man sollte das menü als ganzes
wahrnehmen weil das zeichnet doch ein
klares bild dieser person annalena
baerbock das was sie inhaltlich wichtig
ist und jetzt auf dass nichts den tieren
einzelner zutaten alleine abzustellen
sagen nimmt dem sagen dem worum es
eigentlich geht sagt uns warum da wohl
auch ist so darauf herumgeritten wird
waren anscheinend keine lust hat
inhaltlich noch nicht einzusteigen weil
die schlechte auch viele gar nicht
glauben auf der inhaltlichen ebene
gewachsen zu sein wenn das ist ja häufig
der fall wenn ich ab person am anteil
ist das ja auf die kapitulation von der
inhaltlichen argumentation fähigkeit
oder so
wenn man solche technischen fehler
anmerken cdu/csu haben inhaltlich
kapituliert oder andere haben inhaltlich
kapituliert sagt der grüne
oberbürgermeister von wuppertal
wir hören noch mal in das rhein war es
annalena baerbock gesagt hat zu dieser
motivation was könnte die motivation
gewesen sein um sich jetzt dieses buch
vorzunehmen da hat sie sich am
donnerstag zu geäußert bei dem regierte
in dieser veranstaltung wirklich dinge
zu erneuern besser zu machen heißt
natürlich auch manches anders zu machen
als bisher und da gibt es natürlich
kräfte auch im land die sagen nein wir
wollen diese veränderungen nicht und
deswegen ist dieser wahlkampf aus meiner
sicht hat aber das haben wahlkämpfe wie
immer noch mal an sich airplus kräfte in
diesem land die die grünen verhindern
wollen weil dieses land verändern wollen
also etwa haben wir als union in den
vergangenen tagen einen sehr starken
inhaltlichen fokus
und dass jetzt dieses jahr stellen
aufgekommen sind das hat ja mit der
union nichts zu tun sondern darin ja
unabhängige jahres forscher auf die sich
ja die grünen in den vergangenen jahren
teilweise auch sogar bezogen haben das
ist das eine
aber was ich hier auch entscheidend bei
der ganzen debatte ist dass die grünen
überhaupt keine kritikfähigkeit an den
tag legen
jeder angriff alles was irgendwie auch
hinterfragt wird und was in einer freien
demokratie auch notwendig ist dass es
hinterfragt wird wird gleich extrem
abgekanzelt und mit beleidigungen wird
geantwortet wenn ihr zum beispiel jemand
wie herr kriesche aktion zu der grünen
einlassen verantwortlich macht wird ote
in kanada vancouver hat nochmal zeigen
von denen krischer dem stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden sind wir aber ganz
fair und sage ja krischer hat sich dafür
mittlerweile entschuldigt mit einem
sorry einem weiteren tweet er ein paar
stunden später kam und hat versucht das
geradezurücken
trotzdem er hat in diesem ersten tweet
indirekt vernaschen mitverantwortlich
gemacht für tote er koste seine politik
koste menschenleben
oder frau wiener sind sie stolz dass
solche tweets von ihren parteikollegen
kommen finden sie das angebracht in so
einer situation ist das zu übers ziel
hinausgeschossen
ich finde das gut dass herr krieger sich
entschuldigt hat und das zurecht gerückt
hat erstens hat da muss man natürlich
jetzt auch sagen wenn man so alles auf
den tisch legt hat er ja nicht gesagt
lastet ist und zieht auch nicht gemeint
lasse ihre in mörder und dann vielleicht
eher lässige fahrlässige tötung durch
hilfe unterlassung und das so in dem
sinne nicht nur vorstellungen hat er
sich eine andere taktik katastrophen
einfach emotional berührt und gerührt
gefühlt und müssen da übers ziel hinaus
geschossen aber es kann noch viele
weitere beispiele heute hat eine grüne
bloggerin
gerade für die grüne bayern kandidiert
hat new york geworden dass sie bewusst
die schüler krank machen
es ist ein junior probst hat irgendein
beispiel von den grünen was wirklich
unter die gürtellinie gehen und deswegen
auch mein appell bitte kommen sie zu
einem fairen wahlkampf zurück und das
wird die allagui darzustellen aufgedeckt
werden von vw aber das hat auch nichts
mit der union zu tun und damit der fdp
oder mit anderen politischen
wettbewerbern sondern dass die alleine
aber vorerst gewinnt vielleicht einmal
ganz kurz dazu herr schneidewind das ist
jetzt natürlich ein winziger ausschnitt
aus ihrer partei frau probst das war bei
herrn christ schon ein bisschen anders
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
im bundestag das war auch beim
grünen-sprecher etwas anders andreas
kappler der ja rufmord dieses wort
benutzt hat müssen sie das strenger mit
sich selbst sein sie haben sich eine
selbstverpflichtung aufgelegt für diesen
wahlkampf unfairen wahlkampf zu führen
müssen sie da einmal in der partei
sprechen wie das jetzt weitergehen soll
in den nächsten monaten wie man da
welchen ton man da pflegen möchte ja
also ich glaube in dem stück mehr
gelassenheit wäre sicher sogar renner
gewesen also markt einfach im wahlkampf
liegen da vielleicht auch viele nerven
blank wenn ich glaube wir können stolz
darauf sein dass ich bin zwischen stolz
auf in einer partei zu sein in der ich
vorsichtig
viele andere kluge bücher schreiben
indem wir einfach extrem inhaltlich
überzeugende konzepte haben und wenn
dann immer wieder diese ad personam
angriff getroffen und sich alleine
darauf reduziert wird ich glaube dann
hilft nur souveränität nur weil die
emotional aufgeheizt da man darauf
reagiert lässt man sich ja auf das spiel
des antrags sachen also daher hoffe ich
auch dass wir da wird für die nächsten
wochen noch mal ein stück daraus lahm
wir sollten titel selbstvertrauen
einfach darauf darin haben dass die
konzepte die wir für die zukunft
anbieten die überzeugenderen sind und
uns schnell wieder halten
ich will eine schnelle frage in die
runde werfen mit bitte um handzeichen
einmal wie abstimmung im bundestag
sozusagen die ist ein bisschen
theoretisch aber glauben sie dass angela
merkel bundeskanzlerin gewesen wäre wenn
vorher rausgekommen wäre sie hatte in
einem buch so viel abgekupfert wer
glaubt dass sie trotzdem bundeskanzlerin
geworden wäre glaubt niemand glaubt ich
glaube hält es für möglich
ich schneide sagt auch es ist eine total
theoretische frage ist trotzdem spannend
sie ist tatsächlich es kann doch nicht
nur um eine person geben einen kleinen
ausschnitt sondern auch um die fähigkeit
ob man jemanden zu trauen
dieses amt auszuführen und zwar gehört
mehr dazu als black ganzen leben jetzt
nicht mehr teurer und nach der summe an
themen wie bau der burg rausgekommen
sind wenn jemand hier seiten beide dinge
zusammen kopiert und dann sagt aber ich
bin die neue kanzlerin also ist hier
wirklich die doppelmoral und die
hochstapelei das problem mit baerbock
louis das nicht mehr
also haben hier im land angerichtet
würde wenn diese frauen ihr einfluss
hätte und wenn die grünen wenn trittin
der strippenzieher ist dabei und doch
war es vorne auf pump aber wenn die
krise klausuren akteure mit laschet
jetzt vor wenigen wochen passiert wäre
und nicht vor einigen jahren habe dann
hätten wir doch die gleiche debatte da
hat jemand klausuren verloren das ist
und das haben sie
stellt man offen mit umgehen können das
haben sie deshalb einmal ganz kurz
geordneten ganz bei fribourg ist ja
unterm strich nicht ganz verstanden
einmal ganz kurz geworden
ganz kurz ungeordnet alle übereinander
durcheinander
deswegen noch einmal die frage an herrn
weber um nochmal über das ausmaß dieser
ja kopien plagiate wie sie sagen zu
sprechen er weber sprechen sie auch von
urheberrechtsverletzungen sind das
urheberrechtsverstöße in ihren augen
ich habe von anfang an gesagt in meinem
blog das war mein erster titel am montag
strenggenommen liegen auch
urheberrechtsverletzungen vor und an
dieser einschätzung hat sich nichts
geändert und diese einschätzung wurde ja
mittlerweile von einem juristen eines
öffentlich-rechtlichen senders diese
einschätzung wurde mittlerweile vom
volker rieble der einst führende
sachbuch über das plakat geschrieben hat
und weiteren juristen bestätigt
natürlich werden sich in der juristerei
dann wieder fünf finden lassen die das
gegenteil sagen entscheiden diese hier
dieser begriff der schöpfungshöhe ja
also waren ist eine formulierung sorgen
dass sie eine eigentümliche geistige
schöpfung ist aber das ist ein
nebenschauplatz
aber er geht es darum dass jemand copy
paste dann startet das er selber
schreibt verstehe und ich sage es
nochmal das gegen zu orthodox ja wie von
der kanzel gepredigt wir haben in
unserer kultur seit 1730 im buchdruck
die idee dass ein buch auf dem annalena
baerbock oben steht von der annalena
baerbock stammt von mir das noch von
diesem herrn edmaier passagenweise diana
der baerbock hat uns betrogen indem
dieses buch von stark derzeit 16 oder 18
anderen leuten stammt wie sie zusammen
geschnippelt hat und das ist zutiefst
unseriös das ist zutiefst unmoralisch
leute die sowas tun die kriegen an der
universität in nordrhein westfalen eine
geldstrafe von bis zu 50.000 europas
diverse studien 39 spielen herr weber
apropos universität ist noch drin
westfalen oberbürgermeister in wuppertal
der selber ja wissenschaftlich
gearbeitet hat ist das tatsächlich ein
riesenunterschied aber sie müssten ja
jetzt wenn sie dort tätig während
weiterhin ihren studenten sagen mensch
die darf das aber bei euch böse böse wie
gesagt dass wir haben's ja ein völlig
anderes genre zu tun wenn sie sich die
meisten politischen bücher von
spitzenpolitikern anschauen die sind das
sind lauter solche koproduktionen
da kommt das meiste was das wurde genau
von diesen co-autoren das ist aber
entstanden in gesprächen mit den
jeweiligen politikern und politik haben
das geht über alle parteien hinweg also
dann würde ich jetzt auch er nicht
aber entscheiden so funktional der
realität gerade hatten allseitiger
wissenschaftliche arbeit dies weil die
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten werden ja eh
nicht gelesen von der bevölkerung dieses
buch wird gelesen da ist er ein harte
kommerzielle kalkulation dahinter das
wurde von der frau federschmidt meiner
österreichische journalistin kollegin
rezensiert das hat die frau gabi im
spiegel rezensiert dieses buch wird er
im gegensatz zur die situation von herrn
guttenberg die ihr eh nur in einer
kleinen scientific community blase
rezipiert wird dass wir den ernst
genommen und jetzt wird hier ein sub
text entfernt nämlich dass hier ganz was
anderes drin ist dass das gar nicht die
formulierungen der frau baerbock sind ja
sind zwar nicht bös weil sich immer
sagen naja du schon jetzt nennen als
fachbuch während man den ersten
buchstaben dann heißt sachbuch wie wird
es da noch heißen 1 8 buch vielleicht
nach um gottes willen ich das alles
probiert aber sie passt dass ich so viel
schlimmer wenn in so einem buch plagiat
ist und ich kann ich kann den
plagiatsbegriff er nicht aus einem
schauer aus nehmen nur weil es jetzt
eine politikerin trifft sie müssen sich
einmal mit zu tragen
edition braut machen wenn sie und ohne
unterricht also ich bin wirklich ich
sage das ist schon ein niveau wo ich
ihnen sagt ich weiß nicht ich habe mich
jetzt nicht genau mit dem herrn
oberbürgermeister beschäftigt aber wenn
er an der uni unterrichtet dann muss er
doch wissen dass der plagiatsbegriff
nicht auf die wissenschaftliche texte
beschränkt ist oder noch ein bogen
gespannt
würden sie schwieriger wie würden sie es
den schülern und schülerinnen in hamburg
erklären das ist ja jetzt ein fall über
den ganz deutschland spricht wenn
schüler und schülerinnen natürlich nicht
abschreiben dürfen in der schule
wie vermitteln sie denn dass das eine
sehr berechtigte frage
frau berg erinnert an eine schülerin die
beim abschreiben erwischt wird und als
erstes mit den menschen land die schuld
gibt und ich finde die reaktionen von
vblock auf die affäre und auch die
vorwürfe dass sie traktierten die sind
noch viel schlimmer als die eigentliche
sache denn sie hat ja nicht souverän
reagiert oder gesagt sie geht auch diese
vorwürfe ein sondern sie hat als erstes
einen medienanwalt eingeschaltet um auch
die presse in deutschland unter druck zu
setzen der gleich mit einem anwalt
reagiert und sie ist nicht in den discos
gegangen und von einer person die
bundeskanzlerin von deutschland werden
möchte kann man doch erwarten dass sie
auch auf solche vorwürfe so war reden
reagiert und die grünen haben in den
vergangenen tagen gezeigt dass sie nicht
das zeug zum regieren haben soweit die
diskussion mit dem plagiatsjäger mit
stefan weber der sich hier vor allen
dingen natürlich gezockt hat mit den
beiden grünen wir wollen jetzt
herzlichen dank weder für diesen moment
wir wollen diese affäre bernburg diesen
fall berbalk jetzt weiter politisch
bewerten und politisch diskutieren und
wir haben frau wiener jetzt gerade
gelesen dass ausgerechnet die taz in
ihrem kommentar schreibt ja eine
rücktrittsforderung äußert gegenüber der
grünen kanzlerkandidaten frau werber und
sie schreibt wenn sie das klima retten
soll dann sollte sie jetzt zurücktreten
das ist ja knallharte das kommt also
ausgerechnet ich würde mal sagen aus den
grünen ist ein bisschen übertrieben aber
zentralorgan taz was bedeutet das trifft
diese kolumne trifft dieser kommentar
mittlerweile eine stimmung sogar bei den
grünen insight
also ich hab den kommentaren nicht
gelesen aber ich kann ihnen sagen auch
wenn hier sehr viele menschen
von der cdu von der csu und von der fdp
und von der afg gerne hätten das projekt
jetzt auf ihren wunsch zurückgeht werden
dass noch immer die grünen unter sich
ausmachen und nicht via media hier
journalisten auch nicht
ich hätte auch gerne andere bundes
kandidaten bei den anderen parteien aber
es interessiert niemanden muss man sagen
ja und wenn jetzt menschen meinen auf
diese die ich sage völlig überforderte
unangemessene diskussion wie aus dem
ruder läuft messen weil menschen und
seinen offensichtlichen rutscht ja ein
starkes mittelpunkt stehen hat und meint
dass eine eigene arbeit so wahnsinnig
wichtig wäre dass das jetzt konsequenzen
für deutschland waren löste in der
zukunft an bin ich nicht dieser meinung
aber er scheitet wir müssen noch etwas
lernen kann und muss und was seid ihr
zugestanden wie jeden anderen kandidaten
der auch mal klein angefangen hat und
jeder jeder von diesen privaten hat
fehler gemacht
ihr seid nicht frau bierbauch und ich
weiß sie ist eine kluge sie ist eine
kämpferin sie hat mutige ideen und on
the talk kommt dass wir einfach eine
andere politik brauchen wir brauchen
eine transformation hört und ganzen
fließen gefahren und was ist das wesen
und nur offenbar wird sie innerhalb der
grünen partei mittlerweile infrage
gestellt dass insinuiert zumindest
dieser taz kommentar heute wie gesagt
ausgerechnet die taz schreibt dass herr
schneide wenn das ist schon interessant
wir müssen noch mal im moment bei diesem
kommentar bleiben eben weil er nicht von
der faz kam weil er nicht vom cicero kam
weil er nicht von der welt kam nicht von
der bild kann weil er nicht von der cdu
kam und so weiter sondern weil er von
der taz kommt trifft das eine stimmung
mittlerweile bei den grünen ist er
möglicherweise sogar gestreut von
menschen die robert habeck nahestehen
was kaum sie sind bestens vernetzt in
der partei also ich habe das überhaupt
nicht also ich glaube es geht jetzt ja
auch ein stück um politische kultur also
wenn man zu diesem schritt gehen würde
wäre das ja wirklich eine kapitulation
vor diesem wahlkampf der sich reduziert
auf solche formalen handwerklichen
fehler die nicht schön sind aber wir
diskutieren jetzt ja darüber welche
grundsätzliche richtungsentscheidungen
wir im september treffen an der in
abwehr wie auch mit ihrem perspektiven
verkörpert dort die partei hat eine
massive unterstützung bekommen es muss
jetzt darum gehen mit aller gelassenheit
wieder auf diesen inhaltlichen pfad
zurückzukehren und das nehme ich auch
als stimmung in der gesamten partei war
also von daher weiß ich nicht was die
frage ja ein sozial zündung für diesen
touch kommentar gegeben hat aber ich bin
nicht in der partei
das weiß ich ja auch nur ist es
natürlich schon interessant man stellt
den kandidaten natürlich vor nach vorne
mit dem man am ehesten glaubt die wahl
gewinnen zu können und wenn sich daran
jetzt zweifel breit machen dann ist es
natürlich schon spannend wenn ein
solcher kommentar ausgerechnet von der
taz auftaucht was ist frau wiener ihre
interpretation dessen dass ausgerechnet
robert habeck gerade schweigt zu dem
fall
da wirst du sie wenden berger und
schweigt und souverän sind dann sagt man
nur die feigen weiß also wie man es mag
haben uns nur als machen
ich finde gut was er schweigt denn das
ist natürlich gern vor so gesagt ein
bisschen öl ins feuer gießen
das wird dann so ähnlich funktionieren
ich finde dass es ein bisschen also man
könnte ich als frau gerade und als
unternehmerin und dass alleinerziehende
weiß wo und ab ins beet für frauen
wollten uns erfolgreich sein wollen also
ich bin das schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig wie also auch gerade mit
brown auch in den sozialen medien und
auch in der politik umgegangen wird und
deswegen kann ich ihnen sagen
ich habe nichts gehört ich bin immer das
möchte ich auch noch mal klarstellen ich
verteidige jetzt sozusagen die ideen der
grünen die werte der grünen und damit
auf top werber möchten wir hier was hat
eigentlich bin ich meine deutsche grüne
also man kann ja nicht vorstellen dass
ich hier jetzt weit haben mach das mal
worden
das macht sondern das ist wichtig dass
ich scheine eben doch und das trifft
nicht unpersönlich wenn man mir sagt
offensichtlich keine moral und meine
werte und das zeigt sie vielleicht
angelernten fußnoten weil einer von uns
einer von uns ist moralisch einwandfrei
und integer auch niemanden und es muss
auf einen politiker und politikerinnen
zugestanden seinen fehler machen zu
dürfen und aus den fehlern zu lernen
wir sprechen nur darüber ob er den
grünen hat los unter einer ob auch bei
den grünen frau berbalk im moment noch
den rückhalt hat und da ist eben zeichen
darauf dass das verhalten von herrn
saerbeck im moment zeigt dass er sich
eben nicht mit voller verve hinter die
kanzlerkandidatin gestellt hat sondern
er hat ein paar ganz schmale sätze
gesagt im zdf als mit cherno jobatey ein
bisschen wandern war schon wieder mal
kurz rein
es sind fehler gemacht worden in den
letzten wochen den letzten wochen vor
dem parteitag wirklich sagen aber die
fehler wurden nicht in der
bundesgeschäftsstelle können sie uns
diesen herr schneidewind satz
interpretieren die fehler wurden nicht
in der bundesgeschäftsstelle gemacht
sagt robert habeck das heißt also die
partei ist es nicht schuld sondern die
kandidatin selbst und dann will ich
jetzt auch nicht in der exegese gehen so
da bin ich dann auch wieder nicht daran
also ich glaube für robert habeck ist
das wirklich eine ausbeute situation
weil er nun selber ja jemand ist der
buch inspirierende bücher in den letzten
jahren geschrieben hat und ich glaube
bei seinen büchern da auch gerade was
das zitieren angeht die sehr hohe
standards anlegt und dann ist also man
das was da passiert ist also ich glaube
da sagen ärgert man sich auch innerhalb
der grünen partei dass das wäre mit
wenigen formulierungen vermeidbar
gewesen
es bietet jetzt eine schlanke die in
einer intensität hineingegangen wird und
ich kann erobert habe ich sehr gut
verstehen dass jetzt auch nicht über
geht diese form dass das des handwerks
zu rechtfertigen als jemand der dabei
seine bücher weil der stadt st
weil der stoff sauer sein wird also über
diese diese fehler natürlich war ich
würde mit meinen worten sagen
gelegentlich gedemütigt worden also wir
kennen alle diese szene wo annalena
baerbock mit ihm auf der bühne sitzt und
sie tut ihnen da ab als schweinebauern
während sie völkerrechtlerin ist so
bezeichnet sie sich das war eine
demütigung eine andere natürlich vor
allen dingen die tatsche dass die
kanzlerkandidaten dann wurde und robert
habeck hat sich ja auch so geäußert dass
er das gewissermaßen unfair fand dass
sie dann diese frauen karte gezogen habe
obwohl man doch verabredet hat dass das
nicht der punkt sei mit dem man am ende
die kanzlerkandidatur ausmacht also
möglicherweise gedemütigt worden und
dann merkt man das rennpferd das renten
nicht richtig sondern die partei die
geht gerade immer weiter runter immer
weiter runter hat historisch eine
riesen-chance frau wiener und dann
verspielt man das jetzt durch falsche
lebensläufe durch nehmen
dienste den ich angegeben werden durch
ein buch bei dem man nicht sauber
gearbeitet hat also dazu sagen ich 2
wenn herr robert das gewesen geworden
wäre hätten garantiert irgendwas
gefunden um auch einzuschenken
das wäre ja sie die menschen die jetzt
meinen das ist jetzt der entscheidende
punkt ja sozusagen die grünen jetzt
ruiniert hat und aber wer soll das sein
dass er ganz kurz vor wieder
entschuldigen
wer soll das sein das immer so schnell
dahin gesagt das handy die sind richtig
politische gegner von anderen fraktionen
menschen die ich schon immer gesagt
haben von denen ich mir anhören muss
die links vorsitz begrünen das sind
leute die mir auch in den social medias
schreiben also was ich für für eine
verbots partei binde und präsident
unmoralisches das sind auch journalisten
die an zwar zurecht themen aufnehmen
andocken denn ziell argumentieren und
der also der aufklärung und der gesamten
geschichte weniger raum geben also wir
wissen dass es nicht so gewesen wäre
dass das jetzt deutschland oder in
teilen deutschlands haben hätten und
gesagt das machen wir jetzt angst das
ist das eine das andere was ich aber
sozusagen denn sie vom klinikum sprechen
möchte ich nicht an doch da waren als
die bäuerin was die aussage man würde
von tom leighton kommen von von
schweinen oder von 9 aus täglich neue
ausdrücklich aus
und das habt ihr hier genau genau so
gesagt dass es mir auch eine
herzensangelegenheit ausdrücklich nein
aber es kam auf den ausdruck von frau
werbung in dem moment ein und der war
nicht wertschätzen gegenüber
schweinebauern in dem moment aber lasst
ihr uns über den punkt einmal
hinweggehen
das ist tatsächlich ein punkt von frauen
fehler den ich hundertprozentig zeichner
aber es war eben in dem moment in meinen
augen doch eine demütigung weil es
einen jahr verächtlichen tonfall hatte
aber sei es dahin gestellt wir wollen
einmal darüber sprechen wie sie haben
gerade frau wiener den punkt schon
gemacht mit der frauen karte sozusagen
also schaut man wirklich bei frau berg
noch genauer hin weil sie eine frau ist
das sagt sie selbst dazu am vergangenen
donnerstag bei der brigitte
es kommt meiner wahrnehmung bei mir
selber aber auch bei vielen vielen
anderen frauen halt immer so eine
zusätzliche ebene mit dazu es gibt
natürlich heftigste angriffe jetzt auch
ja also mit blick auf grüne mit blick
auf klimapolitik mit blick auf alles
aber bei frauen gibt es immer noch eine
zusätzliche angriffs ebene gerade wenn
man das argumentative argument ausgeht
dann ist habe ich meiner rede gesagt gab
es auch eine diskussion darüber dass
plötzlich die stimme zu schrill oder das
kleid zu lang oder zu kurz oder wie auch
immer zu farbig stimmt dass herr
aiwanger und wenn ja warum lassen sie
das zu in der politik als man jetzt
einmal die männer hier in der runde habe
warum lassen sie das zu da seine frau
berbalk das wie sie sagt schwerer hat
nach wie vor das bei ihr genauer
hingeguckt wird kritischer hingeguckt
wird also ich glaube das ist ja jetzt
das lebt die rückzugsgefecht geht's die
frauenporträts hüten auch die motoren
und zeigt mal nicht so ich bin durchaus
gut mir leider ist kann ich nicht
mitgehen - sagt man hätte auch etwas
gefunden sie auch wenig überzeugt umso
besser ist es jetzt auch auf ihr volk
durchschaut worden ist und ich bin
überzeugt dass auch habe durchschaut
worden wäre wenn jeder kandidat gewesen
wäre obwohl ihr machen ist weil auch bei
habe ich die auf viele dinge nicht rund
waren dass er inhaltlich ja nicht
belastbare antworten und die viele dinge
nicht wusste dinge die in politischer
fünfklässler wissen müsste also auch die
er wie er dem kanzleramt nicht gewachsen
gewesen wir brauchen hier jetzt nicht
die frauen oder männer vor die zocken
sondern wirklich was ist an substanz
dahinter marina horn ist ja vorher
selber ein bisschen an getextet mit dem
uhr wird der doppelmoral und genau
darauf läuft es jetzt immer mehr aus die
grünen sind gewohnt in das establishment
anzugreifen immer ans bein zu pinkeln
anderen und
jetzt plötzlich stellen sieht es das
auch die etwas genau unter die lupe
genommen werden und es ist schon
bezeichnend wenn man jetzt plötzlich so
von den medien würden die grünen nicht
genügend unterstützt ich glaube dass
frau die ihr buch geschrieben und hoch
gesendet wurde immer in geologische
großen wie vom himmel herunter
strahlend dies sind dinge die wurde groß
geschrieben über ihre substanz hinaus
und da kommen wir jetzt genau und den
punkt die grünen die immer und andere
dinge einfordern diese selber nicht
lieber in den urlaub fliegen dann nach
hause kommen und muslime demonstrieren
andere im land ausbauen von goisern
verbieten wohl und silber im grünen ohne
den bauern zusammen holt die partei das
ist das was frau wiener gerade sind und
dergleichen er also doch kommt jetzt die
ganze grüne doppelmoral schon die finger
reimer bei diesen frauen punkt bleiben
weil ja nicht nur frau berbalk das sagt
sondern in der heutigen bild am sonntag
auch die bisherige familienministerin
franziska giffey die sagt genau das auch
die sagt dass frauen in der politik
härter angegangen mit ihnen hertha
umgegangen wird in der politik
herr schneidewind wuppertaler
oberbürgermeister grüner ein mann und
gleichzeitig bei den grünen platz sind
sie bei der frage fast ein objektiver
beobachter ist das so hat frau gerächt
hat frau berbalk das recht da recht dass
frauen härter angegangen werden in der
politik ja absolut
es gibt diesen geschlechter weiß ich
meine der hat jetzt auch der dieser
ganzen kampagne damit zu tun das
natürlich in der frage wie kann man
damit umgehen die kann man adäquat
darauf reagieren ist in der gesellschaft
viel akzeptierter ist dass männer mit
seiner basta einstellung ich möchte wenn
ja hat schröder in so einer situation
vorstellen ich glaube dass er sehr viel
schneller abbauen zu können weil das
etablierte muster sind das wissen wir
und ich würde das jetzt gar nicht zur
dämonisierung des politischen gegners
verwenden dazu ist in der opposition
wird extrem gute arbeit gemacht man da
kennt die fragen kann man erkennt auch
wo die besondere flanke ist wenn man
hier eine frau als spitzenkandidatin hat
das hat man jetzt bei dieser kampagne
hervorragend gespielt aber die antwort
muss im 2
da souverän durch zu gehen also nicht
warten können wir uns von armin laschet
einiges abschauen ich mein was hat der
in details durchgemacht
sie ist machen herr schneidewind ganz
kurz wie würden sie es dann machen den
souveränen durchgegangen ist vor berbalk
da ja bisher nicht
das heißt was was wäre der weg für
dieses jahr wirklich ist das erste mal
an der intensität dass ihr das so mit
voller wucht erwischt und ich glaube das
ist etwas was macht ein starker annalena
baerbock ist eine extrem kluge und
lernfähige frau und die nächsten wochen
werden jetzt zeigen wie es der partei
und ihr auch gelingt wieder auf das
zurück zu spenden worum es am 26
september also sie muss nicht in weiten
stellung zu dieser republik und die
zuversicht dass ihr das gelingt
lernfähig bedeutet sie muss noch lernen
also ganz konkret jetzt wieder zu den
partei themen zurückzufinden wir waren
noch einmal herr bloß bei dem frauen
thema das ihr ganz wichtig ist denn frau
berbalk spricht davon vdv unterstützt
das heute in der bild am sonntag stimmt
das dass frauen auch von ihnen vom vom
politischen gegner härter angegangen
werden als wenn jetzt beispielsweise
herberg an der stelle setzte auch hier
zeigt sich die doppelmoral gerade die
grünen und von einigen linken im land
denn als es in den vergangenen jahren
angriffe auf merkel gar habe ich das von
den grünen
da habe ich das von linken im land nie
gehört das heißt auch hier werden
unterschiedliche maßstäbe angelegt aber
ich möchte noch mal das aufnehmen was
der schneidewind eben auch völlig zu
recht gesagt hat wir haben ihn ja shell
hatte auch in den vergangenen monaten so
viel einstecken müssen wie kaum ein
anderer im land ist gab spiel cabling
wird zunächst stand traut werden vw top
gehalt wurde vom spiegel vom stern von
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien und vielen
anderen
gerade die union wird man ganz viel
medien auch sehr hart angegangen und
wird ist werden viele aussagen aus der
genau überprüft und die grünen erleben
jetzt als erste mal dass auch aussagen
dass die bücher dass irgendwelche
veröffent
richtig eine kontrolle einer prüfung
unterzogen werden und anscheinend sind
die grünen gar nicht mehr darauf
eingestellt mit mann oder frau hat es
aber überhaupt nichts zu tun
und das muss man glaube ich auch hier
ganz klar das ist ein ablenkungsmanöver
der grün und von einigen linken in
deutschland frau wieder was wir gerade
erleben ist schon ja etwas mehr als
wahlkampf das geht schon in die richtung
schlammschlacht von seiten der grünen
auch also was frau burke auch bei der
veranstaltung der beginne noch mal
gesagt hat sie hat selber von fake news
gesprochen sie hat von kampagnen gegen
ihre personen gesprochen wir haben den
tweet von ihrem sprecher gesehen der von
rufmord spricht wie oliver krischer
zitiert usw
das heißt die grünen machen jetzt damit
bei einer solchen schlammschlacht trotz
selbstverpflichtung fairer wahlkampf
aber er weiß es schauen sie meint das
sympathische an den grünen des erstens
da zuckt noch was sie sehen offenes
visier
noch werden sie dann sie sich von den
anderen etablierten parteien noch lernen
nichts zu sagen zu schweigen sich
abzuschlagen und sagt was stehe nicht
nur einfach nicht herum zuckender lebt
nichts mehr
das ist das eine andere ist aber was
gehindert auch gegen die wunde von den
herren jeder sagen in einer sechste wird
nun also frauen werden gibt es anders
behandelt wobei man weiß man weiß auch
untersuchungen es gibt also in den
frauen effekt es gibt den die
schlechtere bezahlung sex die junge
erzieherin den heutigen spiegel lesen es
ist mein nach ja sie sagen sie haben es
schwerer als das gerät als gegen länder
aber was nicht geht was mir wirklich ein
bisschen wie soll ich auch
emotionalisiert ist diese arroganz und
diese bösartigkeit persönliche angriffe
gegen eine menschen zu machen weil wir
sind nicht nur alle politikerinnen und
politiker sondern sie sind auch menschen
und jemanden so anzuheben jemanden
persönlich also zu desavouieren zu
beleidigen zu beschimpfen dies ist
gerade gemacht haben und auch der ddr
weber zu
erotische posen wurde sie inszeniert und
gekonnt mixt und sie ist über ihre
substanz das ist so arrogant und
wirklich chauvinistisch selbst
gefährlich wenn ich wünsche ihnen nicht
dass irgendjemand sollten wir wider
nämlich mit franken auf dem cover das
dach war herr laschet dem spiegel und da
stand euch den wird zunächst ich habe
eben nicht mehr bei dem wallach scheint
auch die sneaker und ich wollte ihnen
damit zeigen dass auch eine lasche
extrem hart angegangen wurde
herr laschet hat nutzt oder reagiert und
hat auch beim umgang mit kritik gezeigt
dass er deutlich kanzler ist als ob das
werk kann man meist den religionen
ansehen
104 in der ortslage und rom
geeignet ist das land und die grünen
haben gerade mit fehlender
kritikfähigkeit in den vergangenen tagen
offenbar dass man ihnen das kanzleramt
nicht anvertrauen sollte mein haus mein
erster geistern sie mit den frauen haben
keine nachteile und der zweite halbsatz
ging an jamaika amid a row ganz wie man
andere und redet baselland taiwaner sie
sind auch ganz wien ist gut für die
outlook ist die zeit die sie um runter
geschrieben wurde im gegenteil sowohl
die buch geschrieben um die grünen seite
ist eben nicht gewohnt dass die
journalisten auch mal gegen euch pro
jahren anhalten sagt paulina hary
verhalten sich chauvinistisch und
arrogant sagt frau wiener sie ist und es
ist kein stil kritisierte aiwanger es
mir geht es um die persönliche täuschung
10 machen das ist wahrscheinlich auch
mit der chauvinistische wenn ich das
sage ich sage uns einfach die grüne
waren bisher gewohnt von den medien
getragen worden so dahin braucht ihr
buch wurde maxi buch geschrieben und
jetzt hält sie bis dorthin zurück wo sie
herkommt und jetzt sind die bösen medien
schuld also die grünen sind es nicht
gewohnt auch mal so behandelt zu werden
wie andere politiker behandelt werden
und auch die ausbeute ist man mehr ob
meine forderung ist dass frauen im
politischen tagesgeschäft nicht so hart
angegangen werden wie männer vielleicht
merken es die ein oder andere nicht und
man hat er wieder irgendwelche anderen
vorführen aber ich sage ganz klar wir
brauchen den man auf augenhöhe fachlich
auftreten kann ein mann in der regel die
segel streichen würde bei einer
vorstandswahl monster also habe ich
gegen baerbock da wurde die frau sogar
bevorzugt wahrscheinlich auch weil sie
brauche ist und nicht obwohl sie frau
ist wir habe ich eine frau gewesen die
als moderat geworden oder so dass es
interessante anfange sie sagen frauen
werden sogar wenn sie auf augenhöhe sind
in der politik bevorzugt das ist sehr
ernst er ist es eine einschätzung gehen
sie mal raus in eine vorstandswahl wenn
es um einen vorstandsposten geht oder um
einen listenplatz wenn eigentlich voraus
sagt ich will diesen listenplatz dann
brauchst du es machen in der regel gar
nicht gegen die anzutreten weil du
verlierst also frauen hat ihren deutlich
benachteiligt bieten ihre einfachen hat
bin ich sehr zufrieden weil das aber das
würde ja bedeuten nicht wie kommt noch
das würde ja bedeuten herr aiwanger dass
die frauen nur nicht in den bundestag
wollen weil sonst hätten wir ja
mindestens 50 prozent der
bundestagsabgeordneten weiblich haben
wir aber bei weitem nicht die wollen
einfach nicht
es ist auf alle fälle so dass in den
meisten parteien deutlich mehr männer
mitglieder sind als frauen und daneben
auch bei der aufstellung der listen mehr
männer auch den listen landen und man
sieht es ja dann selbst wenn frau in den
eins zu eins auf der liste sind dann
muss immer noch die räder gebraucht
werden weniger weil sie mir einmal ganz
kurzen strich drunter hier befinden sich
menschen in der runde die sich vor
einigen wochen monaten ja möglicherweise
gut vorstellen konnten miteinander zu
koalieren grün und schwarz so wie sie
das in wuppertal beispielsweise machen
der oberbürgermeister ist das jetzt
schon vorbei wenn man wir im moment die
auseinandersetzung erleben die tief ins
persönliche reingehen wo von rufmord
gesprochen werden wo
hart gegen frau berbalk geschossen wird
wo auf beiden seiten jetzt schon ja
lange lange vor dem wahltag dem
sechsundzwanzigster september wirklich
schwere geschütze aufgefahren werden
wie soll man da menschlich nach dem 26
september grün und schwarz zusammen
passen ja also ich werde gelassen also
ich glaube das was jetzt passiert
das heißt noch nicht solche gräben auf
das ist dann die opposition auch die cdu
geht da in der flanke reihen die die
größe einfach auch durch sehr
unglückliches war handwerkliches handeln
erzeugt haben und dass sich kik und
grüner als die beiden bei den sitzungen
geht wer erzielt das beste ergebnis
natürlich in sona auch orientierten
voneinander abgrenzen das war ja für den
wahlkampf zu erwarten und dennoch glaube
ich dass das eine schwarz grün möglich
machen wird gerade dann von beiden
seiten
wir haben genügend beispiele ob nun auch
kommunale auf landesebene das sehr sehr
produktiv zusammen gehen kann und ich
sehe da noch keine so großen gräben also
dass diese möglich machen per post
teilen sie das also jetzt knallharten
wahlkampf die eine seite wirft den
anderen rufmord vor und nach dem 26
september schüttelt man das nicht so
einmal schüttelt es alles ab und er sagt
man ok freunde wir regieren zusammen
also erstmal möchte ich festhalten dass
gerade wir als union für einen sehr
fairen wahlkampf stehen wir haben auch
in den vergangenen tagen im gegensatz zu
den grünen keine angriffe unter der
gürtellinie vorgenommen und das wird
auch das sein was die union in den
nächsten wochen wenn das bundestagswahl
haben bis auszeichnen wird
wir werden bis ende september bis zum
tag der bundestagswahl vor allem in
deutschland über die frage diskutieren
wer wird den bundeskanzler stellen oder
die bundeskanzlerin
und das wird ein rennen zwischen den
unionsparteien und den grünen sein und
alle bürgerlichen dem land die sollten
union weg wählen wenn sie eine starke
bürgerliche politik wollen mit keine
steuererhöhungen wenn sie wollen dass
das leistungsprinzip ziert und nicht im
wahlprogramm nicht das ganze
wahlprogramm nicht dass laura programm
brachte ist nicht unter cdu de haller
und ich glaub ich größten schnittmengen
tier haben wir als union mit der fdp
ich halte auch jeder reicht aber nicht
doch reicht weil wenn die linkspartei
gut sehr theoretisch üblich und nach der
bundestagswahl werden wir dann sehen
sehr kritisch ich bin bloß noch zum
finale dieser sendung einen ton vor
spielen der kommt von einem ihrer ja sag
ich mal so parteifreunde einem mann der
in den bundestag einziehen will in
thüringen nämlich von hans-georg maßen
und er hat massiv die tagesschau die ard
angegriffen
es gibt genügend länder die man sage mal
ein mdr untersuchungsausschuss einleiten
könnten noch deutsche rundfunk die
tagesschau zuständig wenn man sieht dass
ist ja auch verbindung gibt zwischen der
tagesschau oder zwischen personen die
von öffentlichen rundfunk und arabischer
arbeiten und der linken und
linksextremen szene
dann wäre das wirklich auch eine
untersuchung wird das auch die biografie
von einigen redakteuren mal auf den
prüfstand gestellt wird ob diese leute
die charakterliche eigenschaft haben
auch in der tagesschau die tagesschau
durch redaktion zu begleiten
herr flowers ihr parteikollege hans
georg maßen der will sozusagen eine
gesinnungsprüfung für alle die die bei
der tagesschau arbeiten sie auch ich
halte eine solche äußerung für
inakzeptabel und das entspricht auch in
keiner weise der position der cdu
schwanger teilen sie das was er maßen
sagte oder sind sie auch sie dabei zu
sagen inakzeptabel wenn es um die nieren
morgen soll sich die cdu kümmern
der interessiert mich nicht mehr viel
strom wie können wir deutschland noch
der september soll weiterregieren und
vorher türkei sind die bürgerlichen
müssten cdu wählen ich setze entgegen
die bürgerlichen müssen diesmal freie
wähler wählen damit wir eine neue
bürgerliche kraft in den bundestag
kommen auch das nachzulesen in den
letzten wochen und die grünen nie aus um
ordens da wird ihr gut und wenn die
freien wähler dazu kämen sie sagten
gerade letzte nachfrage herr plus
inakzeptabel bei frau bernburg würde das
heißen sie kann nicht mehr lange
kanzlerkandidat in seine er heißt
inakzeptabel dass herr maßen nicht
länger bundestagskandidat sein kann mit
solchen äußerungen in ihren augen also
diese schlussfolgerungen müssen die
kollegen der cdu thüringen ziehen ich
kann nur sagen wir als haben das ist
doch quatsch das ist doch quatsch sie
sagen ich habe aber dass die das
entscheiden vor ort das ist doch klar
aber trauen sie sich doch wenn sie das
denken dass zusagen oder sagen sie nie
der soll cdu-bundestagskandidat sagen
und im zweifel die menschen abstimmen
lassen und vielleicht gar nicht über die
erststimme in den bundestag einziehen
aber sagen sie doch ihre meinung ruhig
landesverband aber sie sagen doch sogar
über frau berbalk ihre meinung da sind
sie auch nicht im landesverband sie sind
auch nicht in der partei der äußern sie
sich auch knallhart und glasklar können
sie auch weiterhin maßen machen sie
sagen immer total unakzeptabel der
wissende folgenlos der cdu entspricht
aber ich kann für zu den konsequenzen
jetzt aus hamburg nichts über die medien
sagen weil das eine sache der cdu
thüringen ist und ich kann nur sagen wie
wir das hamburger landesverbands
herausgestellt
aber sie können ja sagen ich wünsche mir
dass der zurückzieht dass die neuen
kandidaten aufstellen
ich mache so etwas nicht über die medien
endlich da was zu sagen habe dann
bespreche ich das persönlich mit den
kollegen der cdu türe also melden sich
morgen in thüringen bei den kollegen
auch das mache ich nicht über die medien
also inakzeptabel ist immer schwierig
wenn das deswegen habe ich so haben die
nachgefragte bloß wenn das dann keine
folgen hat wenn es nur bei dem wort
bleibt und anschließend aber alles
andere dann eben doch akzeptiert wird
deswegen wollte ich einmal wissen welche
folgen das hatte ich danke ihnen
herzlich für diese engagierte für diese
total lebhafte und faire muss man sagen
diskussion so war es zumindest in meinen
augen frau wiener herzlichen dank herr
schneidewind herzlichen dank nach
wuppertal für ihren engagierten auftritt
in einer schwierigen lage für die grünen
im moment danke herr aiwanger nach
bayern und danke er bloß das waren die
richtigen fragen hierbei bild am sonntag
abend dieses
sendung haben war kurz vor 21 45
aufgezeichnet wir sind nächsten sonntag
wieder da mit den richtigen fragen
hierbei bild